hello there you're watching the press
preview it's a first look at what is on
the front pages as they arrive well in
the next half an hour we'll see what's
making the headlines that is with rachel
shabby and colvir ranger
so let's take a look at what is on some
of those front pages
well the front of the telegraph pictures
british paratroopers leaving afghanistan
on one of the last military planes out
of kabul their headline britain out of
afghanistan the headline of the express
quotes boris johnson's letter to
evacuating troops saying
we'll be forever grateful
our blood on your hands boris reads the
front of the sunday mirror as concerns
rise for the thousands left in
afghanistan
and the observer reports that thousands
of emails to the foreign office about
urgent cases in kabul were never opened
their headline revealed ministry ignored
frantic pleas to help afghans
and the times also looks to the foreign
office in what they're calling the
afghan blame game as they report
ministers and officials are accusing the
office of negligence
well we're joined tonight by rachel
shabby and colvir ranger very good
evening to both of you i think before i
want to get into some of those front
pages i just really want to mark
what is a historic moment isn't it and
just really to get your thoughts on 20
years of uk
involvement in afghanistan rachel first
to you
well
i mean boris johnson has spoken about
the need to preserve the gains
of those 20 years and looking at it you
have to wonder what exactly were those
gains
um
for me
i think it was the worst possible
invasion u.s and uk led invasion of
afghanistan
the worst possible presence and
execution of that
and then the worst possible exit 20
years later
leaving the country
terrified and in chaos and i think anand
gopal the writer
puts it very well when he says the
trouble
with the u.s led in uk presence in
afghanistan is that
you know there was no real interest in
building a sustainable stable or
democratic state
or country instead what that occupation
did was
um
leave it to be governed by an assaulted
array of private contractors warlords
brought in from outside the country
drug barons and so even the afghans who
maybe did think
perhaps there will be
a positive outcome of this invasion very
quickly realized that they were instead
at the mercy of a system that was
corrupt and repressive
20 years of experiencing night raids
attacks roadside bombs
um
torture
persecution
countless thousands of people who lost
lives and lost their limbs
and so
it's very hard to look at it now on the
eve of the departure
and think
what actually what was the point of that
cover um what about you when you look at
the front page of the sunday telegraph
it says
as simple as simple can be britain out
of afghanistan
what do you want to say about it about
this moment
i think the very first thing i would say
is probably what a lot of people are
thinking is to mark you know the solemn
sacrifice that so many have made over 20
years serving
our country
serving the purpose of peace and
democracy
and serving the purpose of really
helping the afghanistan afghanistan
nation and the people there that has
been the mission the objective now
i think you know we have to recognize
the losses the impact the families the
individuals and those huge sacrifices
that have been made i think that's the
first thing that comes to my mind that i
really want to stress i think secondly i
don't recognize rachel's entire view
there i've been speaking to friends in
the military about what has been
happening over the last 20 years about
the efforts that have been put in the
investment the time the civic
responsibility the
help to that nation the problem that is
absolutely clear right now is how this
exit has been handled and it just has
not been handled well then we have to
look at the united states we have to
look at president biden and ask some
very serious questions about how he has
acted um in terms of taking the
international community with him
having a plan
it seems from all angles there is
confusion there is challenge um there
has been we have left thousands behind
that is just that just can't be right in
this situation after 20 years it should
not have ended like this and i think
there's a latent sense
not enough there's a blatant sense of
disappointment and anger probably at
what is going on at the moment i think
we need to now look at how we go forward
that is going to be the question that
really is on people's lips as we look at
the situation in afghanistan right now
yeah we're going to come on to that
not just
looking at how we move forward but also
what of the fate of the people left
behind um rachel i want to look at the
front of the sunday express the prime
minister of course in a statement has
addressed the entire armed forces
community in which he says we'll be
forever grateful
i mean
i i'm sure that's the case but i would
just like to just um
gently suggest that
you know for the people who did serve in
afghanistan for the for the british
soldiers who served there that picture
is also more nuanced and more
complicated
um
people who signed up to serve their
country in that way
also were not sure entirely once they
arrived and were asked to do what they
were asked to do that that mission
really was about peace and democracy so
i think we need to be careful of
whitewashing the experiences of the
military
and
i think on the other layer we need to be
careful of listening only to the
military so there are several problems
with that interpretation
um but it is true that we have left
thousands of potentially we don't know
how many of people who who helped in
that effort not just helping the
military but helping all kinds of
british contractors in afghanistan
britain had a responsibility to them
sky and other media outlets have spoken
to many of those afghan interpreters who
are now absolutely terrified for their
lives gone into hiding have no idea what
will happen to them and
whatever you think about what happened
before
what is happening right now is utterly
shameful yeah i mean that brings us on
doesn't it cover into the the front page
of the sunday mirror um a quote from a
translator who's in hiding from the
taliban says our blood on your hands
boris and in the statement from the
prime minister he pledges to support
those who have been left behind but it's
not clear is it exactly what that
support is going to look like
no and i think you know again we look at
why has this timetable this evacuation
this biggest movement of people
evacuation of people since world war ii
had to have happened in what appears to
be
a not as well coordinated manner as it
should have been and again i said we
have to look at what president biden has
done here did he take the international
community with him was he clear about a
timeline did he understand the
ramifications of the decisions he was
making these are all serious questions
for a president that seemed hugely
damaged not only and let's be clear on
the international stage but even at home
in the united states yes you can
understand the politics of this and his
personal views of how it it plays in
terms of wanting to bring u.s soldiers
home not wanting to be seen as having
left this for another president but he
could have taken a little bit more time
and i think
there will be blood on people's hands
there is obviously a terrible situation
for people left behind i've also been
hearing about you know the government
sometimes everybody working as you go
into the next phase of this plan
how those two are left behind will be
held there is need there needs to be a
dedicated view of how this will happen
we hear about negotiation of the taliban
i think that'll be the top line at the
moment it's about keeping those people
safe who are left behind i think that's
the first thing that everyone is really
focused on but there is a lot more to be
done here so although this moment this
milestone is a line in the sun there is
going to be a lot more hard work to be
done in international diplomacy by the
international community in ensuring
safety of people in taliban but also
helping whatever government that does
eventually form there understand its
responsibilities i think that's the
biggest challenge to the international
community yeah final thought from you
before we go to the break rachel on the
fate of those who've been left behind
people being advised perhaps go to the
borders if we weren't able to evacuate
you and and sort of vague uh promises
from the prime minister in his statement
saying uh there are these various
schemes and you can you can contact the
ministry of defense for further
information and guidance i mean where
does that leave them when their lives
are at risk
well i cannot even imagine um being in
that state of terror terrified for your
life and the lives of your families and
being told by boris johnson oh yeah just
call this number
just you know just get to the border
it'll be fine i mean it's absolutely
insulting obviously the uk needs to step
up its efforts significantly has very it
has horrible narrow
um
almost no safe routes for uh refugees to
arrive to the uk so obviously that needs
to be looked at and i would just add
that yes biden is responsible for the
um
the way that this happened but also the
uk uk officials had a big role to play
let's not forget that let's not let them
often look sir it's not all afghanistan
on the front pages the observers
carrying a story
about kovid of course the main story
before uh afghanistan
came along to dominate the headlines
saying that covet cases are currently 26
times higher than they were a year ago
and uh presumably cover this i mean as
we know this is before schools in
england and wales have gone back
this is an and the strange thing is
as you go around our country at the
moment and i was in leeds today uh
watching a bit of the cricket actually
but
to a certain degree there's a sense that
things have gone back to normal now
there are still rules in place people
are being careful in areas masks are
being worn and we we are a bit cautious
but there's a sense of normality and i
think that's a good thing that the
country feels that the vaccination
program has been successful but cases
are still there we are living with cobit
this summer i think the question that we
need to ask is what's the plan for
winter because we're hearing news about
potential booster programs it doesn't
sound quite clear at the moment um and
our case is gently creeping up we're
here as you say school's going back soon
as well that will probably increase the
number of cases in a certain way but
still how we're going to manage the
autumn and the winter what is the plan
and i think this is the moment that we
do need to look to the government and to
the health secretary and say please
quickly set out clearly for us a plan
like we had earlier to manage our way to
a point where we got covered under a
certain amount of control but what is
now going to happen with the booster
plan how does that map to the flu
vaccinations and what will be the
timelines in the coming weeks and months
that we can all be confident about
yeah i'm not entirely agree with you
that it feels like things are getting
back to normal but it feels it's almost
so long ago that things were normal that
we've almost
forgotten but i suppose to the extent
that we are learning to live with it
rachel a lot of that is down to the
vaccines isn't it
yeah just to put this story into context
it's 26 times the level of infections
now
than we experienced at the same time
last year so in one week we've got
756
900 people in the uk infected
that is very very high and i agree with
you that i don't think people
are completely feeling like things have
got back to normal um i see a lot of
people still
you know not sure
not going out as much um not being
indoors as much and i suppose you know
that that is the right question of what
are we going to how we're going to
approach winter
schools reopening are going to likely
cause another increase in infections and
what's striking about all this is that
you know all the preventative measures
before lockdown i you know the wearing
of masks and social distancing and
actually just putting any effort at all
from the government into ventilation
which is the huge thing with an airborne
virus
none of that really seems to be present
so
those are the the questions that that
need to be asked of course the
vaccinations are helping my own view on
um boosters are that i don't think um
wealthy countries that have been
hoarding that scene should be
contemplating boosters as long as there
are parts of the world i.e the entire
continent of africa
where you know the majority haven't even
had a first jab
so
that i think is much more of priority
yeah we could uh go into quite a
cul-de-sac couldn't be on the whole
moral implications of all of the vaccine
programme around the world um but before
we go to the break um culver another
story on the front page of the telegraph
talking about the funding demands
coming to the chancellor from the nhs of
course the nhs has already had seven
billion pounds of additional funding had
that back in march but calls to help get
it through
the winter as you were talking about the
likely pressures going to be coming then
for more money again from the chancellor
isn't it i think that plays into the
point of if there's a plan if we can
understand how we're looking to manage
cobit through the winter that will
highlight then where the funding
requirements will be and i think that's
the pressure that the chancellor will be
facing i'm sure he's looking at it right
now he has been a chancellor through
this crisis who has looked to look a bit
more forward than everyone else's in
terms of the plans the policies the
support mechanisms he's put in place
he's tried not to be too short-termism
even in this vastly rapidly changing
environment and i think just to touch on
the reverting to normal i wouldn't say
it's fact and normal but what i did see
were people out and about people
shopping you can see the economy
bouncing back you see people want to
remain confident i think that confident
comes from clear plans from government
about how things are going yes cases are
going up in cases remain high or to us
relatively speaking but the vaccine
program has been the number one thing
that has brought kobe to heal and we
need to keep focused on it and i think
that's the government's uh real target
here that how do they keep doing that
and explaining it to the public yeah so
we can all learn to live with it can't
we